our next guest is a comedy and music
legend fun fact as a kid he collected
license plates from across the country
and now he collects Grammys platinum
albums and Hawaiian shirts here's a look
back at an early hit that put him on the
map oh I love this
[Music]
hey Like a Surgeon
okay I don't talk to him about the lion
he's welcome
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm so excited me too
um that was such an iconic song and
music video back in that moment being at
that video are there any things that
jump out in your mind of like shooting
that day well looking at the Clipper I
saw the lion and that that was a big
part of it because there was a lion in
the original uh Like A Virgin video by
Madonna and we figured well there should
be a lion in the hospital for no
apparent reason
and I remember very well uh you know we
had a lot of extras in the in the video
just you know random people doctors and
nurses in the hallway and when the lion
appeared they said oh this is not worth
50 a day no I'm out of here they left
all right well you know
um everybody sees a Weird Al
um as a right of passage
um if you will do their song and make it
your own has there ever been anyone who
said no
it's very rare most artists look at it
as like you said a rite of passage it's
like they've reached a certain plateau
in their career like you've got your
Grammy and you got your gold album like
where's the Weird Al parody it was like
you know you need the whole Trifecta uh
the the one yeah add that to the egot
that we got the we got yes
[Applause]
yeah we got it uh but yeah the one
person that consistently said no was
Prince uh he you know and I you know he
just was very protective of his music
and I can understand that but it was it
was a bummer for me because I had a lot
of what I thought were pretty good ideas
and he never was into it and people were
like well you know you could probably
ask us a state now and and I don't want
to do that because I've always respected
the artist's wishes and Prince made his
wishes pretty clear so I'm still I still
respect that if you you could cover a
Prince song like if say he like what
what was your vision or or audible
Vision there were there are several um
there was one for When Doves Cry uh and
my movie uh UHF uh it wound up being a
Dire Straits parody but it was
originally a parody of Let's Go Crazy uh
I had a period of 1999 where it was
about like you know some like Mr Popeil
kind of guy selling things on TV for
only 19.99 you know that kind of thing
so I had several ideas but uh it didn't
pan out
um I wanted to ask you a question
because the Hopeless Romantic in me
freaked out when I heard a story about
you and your now wife how did you guys
meet we met through our mutual friend uh
Bill mummy who played Little Will
Robinson on Lost in Space back in the
day yeah and a mutual friend and she
worked for 20th Century Fox as an
executive and I was me and uh and uh he
said oh you guys will probably really
get along and he kind of you know set us
up but we were both really busy I had an
album coming out she was like super busy
at work and we didn't have time to like
actually get together for a date but we
would call each other late at night and
have these phone conversations and this
is pre-social Media I wasn't like
looking her up you know on Instagram or
something I had no idea what she looked
like but we had these conversations late
at night and talked for hours and hours
and I was you know I kind of fell in
love with her just over the phone and we
finally uh had an uh an evening or both
of us had free so we went on our first
State and walking up to the door I still
had no idea what she looked like and I
was thinking well I I kind of hope she's
cute because I'm probably going to marry
her
um I would have married her if she was
homely of course but it turned out she
was a knockout so we got added bonus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]